may i quickly uh go to the restroom
yes you may thanks but you have to come
back yeah i will we're going to talk
about you while you're gone it's right
in there this has never happened this is
a friend really yeah no go for it yeah
don't worry
there are marks in there though keep
rolling on this and i don't want you
editing this out this is the first and
maybe
i think you would be a great wingman for
him i'm sorry
but no i think i would be a good wingman
how would you be a great wingman get in
there oh no
first of all can we can we agree that
this is a first maybe in podcast history
that someone has left the studio
to go
i believe
you don't have to you don't have to
spend it but what i'm saying is that
this is
historic and he has left and now we can
talk about him i should take advantage
of this i do think i'd be a great wing
man there's the flush hurry i do wonder
if he really is going to want to have
dinner with me do you think he really
does want him no i think he just said
that to be nice and it's not because he
doesn't want to i think we're both too
shocked i think he doesn't come back
okay he's coming back i think he'll
slouch but i think this is a good
opportunity for us to get that out
um hey luke did you guys stay live yeah
yeah we did we did this is going out
this is live did you know that this is
going in there you're left in the
bathroom by the way
could you hear us are they piping
could hear you that was a lot of urine
yeah a lot of just like
ah
okay
okay
it is quiet in here this is nice this is
nice
i wonder how long i've been in there you
were gone i wonder how long i've been in
here
uh luke the consensus when you were gone
was a i would be a good wingman sona
said that b
that they don't think this
dinner is going to happen because they
think we're both too shy they they don't
think it's because you don't want to
have it out that's what i think but that
we're we're not going to be able to you
know
consummate this dinner well i mean we
live in the same neighborhood that helps
i think so yeah right yeah so it's you
know already you eliminate the 405 that
that's killed a lot of relationships
right at least it has in my life
one of my children went to school past
the 405 and i haven't seen him since so
i mean it's real it's destroyed families
more than the civil war was the 405
freeway
seriously you know
no i think we're gonna do it you've just
got you're you're a busy guy i mean i
can do it any time what are you talking
about i can just pick a ball in my court
i can do it at the drop of a hat okay
we're going to do it we're going to do
you and i are going to get dinner in the
next two weeks great that's what's gonna
happen wow great and i'm gonna podcast
from the dinner